and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast episode number 40 and it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
we've got gamers vs. ei future of Disney
properties October NPD Game Awards and
Microsoft strategy to discuss so we
don't get right into it so let's
introduce those usual suspects at the
round table
my co-host with the co-host my brother
from another mother and the howl of the
young wolf mommy
Lord addict how you doing sir pretty
good I just want to go on a look like a
little little little mini way all right
exactly you pronounced the people who
make X Kong but I know that their
breakfast for you gotta get your stuff
together because your game or Xbox don't
work and you let me let me explain
I contacted their support group I sent
the ticket in you know what these people
told me to fix this well do they they
told me will log out of your profile
when you're going into the game and the
log back into it which you know I'm
sharing a digital library and I bought
the game so I can't do that if I log out
of my gamertag it kicks the entire game
off so I literally had to delete every
profile on my xbox but the one the
profile just to play the game
are you serious all that just only have
room to kill on my xbox right now now
that's the expansion right yes they knew
even well you're gonna have to do that
too if you want to play Wow I downloaded
two for black francs for Lord would we
know of course most technical gaming
Lord the solo gamer who lives with a
single player selfish experience semi
consistent online profile two weeks good
man he's going good man this past week
was a little little
rough little trying a lot of family
stuff to take care of your nose or
sicknesses to deal with but no yesterday
went out with the Lord's saw Justice
League with de Lawrence and you know it
was good to hang out my boys I'll say
that Lord through propaganda we were
hanging out with Louie true propaganda
last night oh yeah it was going on baby
yes some glorious ale yeah I'll say this
about Justice League I said wait what
that movie between the team that was
good of course the XS gamer the Lord of
cons who is aware of his convictions and
demands nothing less than the premium
experience we loved it
how are you doing little King how we
doing sir I'm doing fantastic all right
so let's get to it real quick before we
get to that other stuff um this weekend
in combat sports started on Friday
middle
you know nobody disrespected his little
baby rant I got to keep all this stuff I
got my nails
are you whining this is that's the
problem with society today guys I gotta
do thing guys all right this weekend it
was it was a really lackluster weekend
I'm not even gonna front the bikes were
good fights but they weren't fantastic
I'm gonna get to the main event on
Saturday and that's it Julian j-roc
Williams where's each skate smell for
when to 12 I mean a 10-round um
lackluster fight yadda yadda yadda we
all waited for rigging down
a llama chinko on a fifth it's going to
be lit that's fighting of the yeah
that's fight of the century actually we
have to um a gold medalist going at it
I'm like these guys that trust me and
it's all free TV that's on ESPN it's
gonna be what's up um they did the Jael
Justice League everybody to Jack yeah
wait you got you gonna get you on a
multiverse yeah I ran together about
this yeah it's not gonna be a real for
me because actually I thought it was
gonna be crap be honest with you I
really did um and um I love the fact
that Josh Whedon went in there like
Superman and he had the same today um
but you looking at what Zack Snyder did
from you know all accounts and
everything's excited tries to watch me
in every movie he's a Michael Bay of
superhero films um the cut and paste and
use the same formula for everything it
doesn't work I don't like the fact that
he tries to make this one dude a
murderer every time he gets these
supposed to be hope and a murder every
chance he gets
every chance to put blood and evilness
in this independent in this almighty
being there has no reason to fear
anything actually he's supposed to be
laughing at stuff and you know you can
say a lot of things for but it was
better to the table with and it's a
great foundation but flashpoint should
fix a lot of things
especially getting rid of that flash
glorious birthday week you know so I got
a chance to catch up Earth Day
much appreciated much appreciate the
round table was represented well I got I
love so it was felt and we got a chance
to celebrate a little bit and catch some
justly which was cool I mean I like the
army was solid but I do feel like you
know Marvel has the advantage of the
build-up and stuff you know as far as
you know so based on what was presented
and based on what I know you know the
history of what's going on with the
studio and all that stuff I thought it
was solid you know so I was pretty much
debt but uh after that you know you
gotta spread that gaming's illness on
the IOP not telling you what you wanna
hear but which you need to hear so are
what are the Lords get into know it's
working after I did on my xbox
there were some old dinosaurs no I'm
glad I missed the Atari I never said
known about the Superman
you didn't have to blow those cashews
you had on the n64 thank you my book
because I'm so happy today that you woke
with yeah we got you Nick don't even
worry about we got we know the
PlayStation when we got you for that
don't even worry about now have you been
playing this week what's going on
not too much sex like I said I wasn't
having at home but um so that that left
me to the switch and I got back into
some Mario got a couple of more moves
you know Mario is a good good kind of
platic palate cleanser you can just play
for a couple of minutes get some moves
and turn that off so I'm in the with the
luncheon the luncheon world so I'm doing
it right now
a little kinetic while getting it Lord
King what have you been playing this
week I wish I could be playing Mario but
I'm telling you right now my soul has
been stolen from Assassin's Creed see
you billing it my game but a year I
found myself doing things I should be
doing laughing out loud and stuff that
shouldn't be funny nothing but skulls
that I can't attack that Far Cry also
has well you can wander into an error
you have no business being in and
boomers come out and
is not is not okay with them spoiling
anything that were you riding your horse
and a pool looking smack you off your
horse and you have that learned fear my
friends or the rabbit hippopotami
savages don't let them catch you in the
water
that's what you be racking okay that's
the soul of the rocket and that's all
I'm gonna rock until it's over I knew
that was gonna happen to my soul I know
that's why I was getting started with
you I'm gonna kind of say boys oh oh one
thing I did one thing I did I spend real
cash in it I spent 14 I got the game for
free right so and I have $200 that was
sitting in my account so I could not let
them have the I arras stick there and I
buy it and then I was like go was really
threw me over the edge as I had long saw
a horse it's at the nightmare package
let me go to the store
Issy right let me just see so into the
store and I said oh no I got that has to
be purchased all right so I went to the
recommendation on what they had and the
recommendation was $49 and it gives you
all this bread literally once you have
the $49 package you can buy everything
the Bounty Hunter's hmm I'm hunting them
and I'm level 21
so we gotta put you at our lord
moneybags first of his name I missed you
last week your presence in the chat is
sorely needed that balance on a command
pretty much the same for me I mean
actually touch Assassin's Creed origins
I was getting that on as so immersive so
much fun Black Friday sale went down
when I cop a cop Tom life is strange
part two got a good discount on it and
um like what a dick I cop the ex-con
water chose and I refuse to pay the full
price on that DLC which never went down
in price but finally writ down in price
for Black Friday so I got that digital
sale going on so yeah ten dollars
doesn't make a huge deal but it's in
principle I won't pay is principle right
like come on y'all know that DLC been
out for man long yesterday
last week the game was more that the DLC
with more expansion in the game bomb man
Boyka bot soo hooking me up with did my
first digital gift or Xbox you hook me
up you got me the Final Fantasy super
deluxe premium HDR version user like so
anyone in the chat that doesn't know
they're gifting I can't wait to give
Lord Lord sovereign they pub G so last
week's the our people results are in and
the people have spoken to the
question now that the Beast has arrived
and Xbox one X has Microsoft kept its
word with the Xbox one X and restored
the feeling the winner at 71% in fairly
dominant fashion was the yes Microsoft
is heading in the right direction and
restored the feeling group coming in at
second only 29% was now this is just a
honeymoon phase
[Music]
turnout was late what are the Lord's
think about we know what Lord King
thinks about Lawson they weren't lying
about the power of the system the system
still surprises you as to what it can do
as a matter of fact yesterday I stopped
by by my parents house and I was able to
see ignore kind of box with Ron um an AC
rogue runs at 60 frames per second off
the rig nothing that's clever like so
it's the system is still surprising you
know what it can do if you go the entire
back long I'm sure you'll find a lot of
little things that pleasantly surprised
you the machine is a beast the the you
know Phil talking about what if it's the
first parting stuffing and so next year
next year to me the year 2l is out the
window I think think only good things
good piece of hardware I'm seeing a lot
of positive response on that's always
good so a shout again shop everybody in
a poll we had a new one cooking up on
the ILP Twitter at the end of the show
so stay tuned so we gonna get into these
round topics on this round Table Topics
ones glorious Sunday my man Lord addict
is up her some some companies might be
scared I don't necessarily think it's
it's companies I think it's a company
yeah you know they made some some shady
decisions when it came to Star Wars
Battlefront - you know with the I don't
think you could technically call this a
pay2win but it's it's almost it's like
in the middle because I feel like a beta
win scenario is something that you can
only get through pain and not playing so
I feel like it's like in the middle but
a lot of people weren't happy you know I
even think some major news outlets
picked this up so what I wanted to you
know bring to the table is Disney
actually got wind of this because they
don't like you know they don't like they
bought the Star Wars brand to promote it
you know obviously they bit off of time
they spent a lot of money on it in with
the read one of the reasons they they do
these Star Wars battlefronts and these
is it's no coincidence that it comes out
around the same time as their movies do
absolutely so they don't want the it's a
complete backlash it's like you're
downgrading the name because of the game
which is supposed to help sell the movie
but as of right now before they made
that call it might have looked like that
game was gonna hurt them so looks like
Disney made a phone call and they fixed
it as a discrete to talk it looks like
the Twitter streets have been very angry
with you with your disrespect of the
Star Wars franchise and lore your
perspective and be able to defend
yourself on the Android platform what's
your feeling on this whole bit so first
off Star Wars I grew up on Star Wars I
was I was the guy who was watching like
Return of the Jedi like every Sunday
never since I was six
okay so your Star Wars happened okay I
was
I so I grew up on it and like I play the
battlefront series in particular I love
battlefront I was amazing I remember I
played it on PlayStation 2 PlayStation 3
I I remember playing it all the time and
it was just I love battlefront and
especially I think what set the tone
first is for this whole Disney
reinvigoration of the Star Wars
franchise is playing battlefront 2015
okay and that was just a god-awful game
it was it was it was it was
well-received it was it was so bad I was
just I just couldn't believe that Disney
would even like sign off on this well I
think Disney like knows a whole lot
that's going on over there or do you
think is he has been doing this whole
big thing lately where they're really
trying to manage their their IPs and
they don't have any loyalty like they
they tomorrow Nathan nature--the
marbleize this away from Activision
they're like okay squares getting this
one Capcom's can get this this this this
and they'd have like no company gets
anything it's the only reason EA has
that is because they had the long term
deal beforehand and so mm-hmm
it's just such a frustrating thing to
watch especially if you're from Disney's
perspective watching EA make these calls
which makes which results in bad product
placement really it is just Brad bad
brand management I mean it's it's
frustrating to watch especially and like
I'm not gonna get in the movies
necessarily except in the movies they're
garbage lately
oh you're young but behind gonna jump up
in here start going franchises when they
making it better for you dinosaurs
you guys are so whole doesn't try to
take you in art I'm glad that you walked
in here with your favorite beef here he
goes we gotta work with these weirdos
let's do it alright so plain to you what
you may not get if I buy something from
you that was profitable and I give you X
amount of dollars I want that money back
and then some so imma have to casual
eyes what you just had is hardcore so I
can bring in the real money and what
Disney is doing is bringing in the real
money while still a piece of certain
people that's why you have a Darth Vader
slash Darth Maul character you
understand so within kylo Ren and D eat
and I love the UH the protagonists and I
love the antagonists in this the the the
female is are going to get up a new base
because that's what they was begging for
before and stuff said instead of having
a feminine heroine in a subservient role
you got one that's in a dominant role so
now that you have that and you also have
a strong male characters that are
surrounding her while giving you same
old characters where you have a Luke
Skywalker everything and building a base
and giving all other you know people the
chance to get on board so you can say
you have problems with the script
yeah maybe okay of course because
remember those first three films was
standalone films and it was over they
blow up the Death Star they keep
bringing this Death Star back so but
they gotta make their money
now I understand you may say oh you may
not like it but you go see it and you'll
get your money counts you vote with your
wallet and I appreciate your side talk
and thank you Donna
goodbye do you feel as far you mentioned
a point as far as like raise the you
know female protagonist stuff like that
in a dominant position and like do you
feel like he's doing a good job of
bringing the young generation to the old
generation like kind of like marriage in
both worlds or but because this connect
Lauren is not feeling it so I just try
to say oh don't give me to that digital
formula is having a strong male role
certain of subservient role you know in
the background someplace like you go do
that sir and you know and then also
having a villain ed is equally strong in
this you have a female that's going up
against a very strong male role because
remember kylo Ren is probably if not the
strongest dog side welder that has ever
been to rival him so we're just trying
to figure out if she's gonna go left
she's gonna go right how's everything
going and the stories are just evolving
to bring in that crowd remember you know
is this bit of a female movement forever
and they're finally starting to get
delight with one woman and the likes you
know these movies are needed necessary
for voice has to be heard the coach for
the coach for gender progression I got
you in here my crush I don't get to walk
track cuz I don't wanna get back to this
the shakiness of EA to say his point
right I'm saying EA had to do that
because Disney looked across the table
and said no no win with Twitter is going
crazy and people are making podcasts
talking only about the loot crate's
and damaging the game before the game is
actually launched if you damage the game
you're gonna damage the movie okay
thanks and they say take it out just
take it out and it was like what we're
not gonna make bread here's some money
take it out Laura saw what are you feel
it was a gamers make that movement
happen let's be clear Disney
was not in the in the dark about this
Disney knew the way the Disney controls
their properties and it will get into my
topic but they they're very controlling
especially of Star Wars and especially
of Marvel stuff um they knew exactly
what was going on now had the the mass
is not you know revolted on this you
would hear zip from them it would just
be in the game and they're making extra
money and they're cool with that the
moment become it becomes a PR issue
where where the success of the game and
like addict said this it's no mistake
that this game comes out so close to the
release of another movie so yeah there's
little there's a domino effect there
they know full well that negative press
permits and and and some people may
argue that Star Wars is impervious to
this right Star Wars no matter what you
see the sales of the first battlefront
people well you like you know it doesn't
matter it's still gonna sell this
they're gonna make some money but you
can only have so much negative press
around something before right the
narrative changes completely around it
and that negativity propagates and it
really affects it and that beyond beyond
the bottom line being affected Disney
cares about perception person yes yes
absolutely
yeah like with the whole thing with at
the Marvel movies and such like even
even though if they have a movie that's
not as good as the other ones like they
because they had that perception of
quality people give it more of a pass it
was cuz they had the idea of like all
they're taking the time they build up
the work and it's because they have that
perception they're able to get away with
a lot more yeah absolutely I mean I
think also we have to keep in mind I
mean didn't this day hit mainstream news
at one point right I was shocked ready
at work and I was just like if someone
says I got EAS new Star Wars Battlefront
that came out is that it's under a lot
of fire a lot of fire hmm absolutely so
it was it was over so I mean let's go
back to again lorac was saying in
reference was so
we had this discussion with Lou boxes
before on previous LP right and how do
we handle it microtransactions what do
we do and what's the best effort and I
want to say like do we feel you know as
far as like because of the strength of
social media in this day and age right
and we seen those reddit posts I mean
call me if I'm wrong Monica
like that reddit post was kind of like
the most gown voted ready whose investor
it was in history who was like over like
six hundred thousand down votes or
something right give me the bag no this
was from the Hoopoe statements I believe
that's right basically they they went
out there and try to damage control
saying like oh we're listening but we're
still gonna do it we're gonna do we
thought we thought this would be a nice
little way to handle this and basically
it was it was an apology without
apologizing it's like we're sorry you're
mad that's it like you could just we
want to make it so that you know you
have to earn it and go through these
hours of progression so you could feel a
sense of accomplishment when you get
your Darth Vader for forty hours to get
Luke Skywalker you're trying you're
trying to shame the victim like you were
victimized by this we're sorry you felt
this way you know
so what addict I know you you you're not
a fan of EA these practices must be good
also what do you feel you feel this is a
w for the gamers like what your whole
feeling on top of it I feel like the
only reason you know I get you know with
the the boycotting thing but I feel like
this is it's one of those occasions
where this won't rarely happen like I'd
be surprised if I see this ever happen
again because with certain companies
like the only reason this happened is
because Disney's not in the gaming
industry blue you know they usually let
people use their IPs to make games and
because it was riding off of a movie
that they have a lot of money invested
into like for the most part when these
games are made
published by again it's published by
gaming something it's a company in the
gaming industry it's made by company in
the gaming industry and they only care
about the money coming in the gaming
industry when it comes to Star Wars
that's leaking over to the movie
industry you know the whatever kind of
action figures or any kind of you know
toys that they're making like Disney
couldn't afford to lose dollars because
EA want to make pennies right
that's dis affair being the brand the
brand is important to them and they seem
not to want any negative connotation
until your point it's like I've never
seen in the history of gaming where the
day before release they acts
microtransactions completely right I've
never seen that usually it's backlash or
whatever so I want to get into that
point before we bleed into a de
saucepans at that you know obviously we
know that it is the W right now that is
the victory it's been removed but there
was it was very crafty very nice buddy l
PR Fievel says the day you know for now
as they figure out you know how to get
the systems working correctly and more
efficiently you know so where I'll bat
with it like yes this is a w for gamers
but let's be clear like don't give
finessed this is coming back I think
what happened is like look you don't
have to ask this stuff but I don't want
to see it till after the movie comes up
exact and obviously I think what they're
gonna do is I think this just set a
precedent for other companies say ok we
might not necessarily be able to put
them don't do this around the launch
don't do it at launch do it not let us
early money get them pre-orders get
everything positive pop and all the
goodwill exact then you sneak it through
the back door you know saying like
there's more to me you know I'm saying
after you know the release is calm again
you go cuz if I
remember come if I'm wrong I remember I
used to play battlefield hardcore and
then like oh that got a feel for let's
say battle for cocaine right and like I
remember like two months into the cycle
you would see these DLCs that would give
you the progression to unlock everything
from the support class in the medic
class you don't remember this stuff so
the same I think what they're realizing
is no we cannot do this ever again in
the beginning of the cycle put it in the
middle cuz make no mistake yard he's a
coming will you boss will literally buy
you and fire everybody
why was gonna say that the thing is like
you're gonna probably see this more
because a lot of reviews now are
reporting on microtransactions this year
has been like microtransactions has been
reported more than any other year on and
IV Burgess has a review like look at on
like shadow of work you look like now
all these games are getting reported on
and so now they they don't want that
negative press and so watch it be from
now on that NAT launch
there's no mic there's no to minimal
microtransactions then all of a sudden
after like after a month or two after
all the reviews are written and
everybody's done then all the Mitra's
actions you put in there we're too late
lately agree completely I think this is
they're realizing what they can and
ghetto can't get away with and I think
that's gonna be the new finesse move
before but they really didn't care what
people said I don't think they expected
Disney to reach the hand sorry I just
brought a super lootcrate from activist
making that available fuzz premium all
this you know in the battlefront wants
to bring the Michel transducers back out
and I can I can pick up Dolph ball for
the early oh I'm down I got some bread
that I want that work let's go talk
about Disney let you rock out bleed it
to this Lord Disney situation backing
off of attics topic and how gamers
manage to scare the crap out of a and
and Disney you know sticking it their
foot in there too because that's very
important my question today is did
Disney make a mistake in getting out of
the publishing and development game and
handing over their third parties and
handing them were their properties to
third-party developers and I know months
ago when when they made it clear they
had completely gone out of the
publishing game and and they and they
announced the Square Enix deal they
announced the continuation of the of the
the Lego deal and then the EA dia we
said you know what this is great because
that they know the strength of their
properties they're handing it over to
these triple-a developers that that have
the infrastructure that have the know
how to handle these properties well and
what without them having to worry about
doing it themselves you know they the
last few games that came out of their
publishing wing you know obviously they
had Disney infinity which was which was
very popular for a long time but when
once the game the toys to life stuff
died down that died with it and then you
have your Epic Mickey 1 & 2 which had
some kind of you know a little bit of a
following but nothing huge so it made
sense to hand over their properties to
these companies now the problem is and
this is where I'm not sure how how much
Disney knows and how much they they
follow it they could my perception is
that they could not have known the
shifts in the gaming industry that we're
going to take this this
especially with EI doing it jumping over
to this microtransaction lootcrate sort
of economy to extend the life of their
games and the negative reaction that was
good that that would have negative
connotations it would have on the
perception of their games and their
properties so it's just one of those
things what do you think and in a lot of
ways they're still better off because
they don't have to do any of that stuff
in house and name it in terms of
creating a game their games are in good
hands in that regards but the business
around it now is very murky and is very
like we've seen it's very capable of
putting a black stain on their most
beloved properties which is absolutely
does not what do you want to know why
why they think this is okay know why
they kept it that way because you morons
cat thought it was okay with Star Wars
Battlefront won almost just as bad
it had no content and they put also
behind season passes and also their
stuff and everyone was ok because it's
Star Wars they put up with it I wasn't
ok didn't have the same a true
single-player campaign oh yeah axes I
like the battlefront 2 campaigns so far
I mean I played me with two missions or
so but I thought at least that they had
a good attempting for my understanding
again I'm not the hardcore Star Wars now
but doesn't this lead up to the movie
but isn't it some type of parallel with
that amount am I wrong it's the it's the
period between Episode six and Episode
seven row that's what already yeah I
mean so far Mesa it seemed good
ah hey what you gonna what Lang trust me
I definitely didn't wasn't a fan of that
first one saw one to jump in I've always
felt that they're the best stories in
the Star Wars universe all the ones
about the worlds what's happening in the
world around like around the galaxy not
necessarily Jedi's and synth and all
this stuff like world work exactly like
oh you ain't started fixing the house
know how anger feels about that just
watching it I just finished watching
rogue once it was my third attempt to
finally watch it took me three days to
watch it biases they just wanted the
issue issue with the Star Wars franchise
now is they're trying to be too similar
to all the ones prior I like the
prequels more than this new stuff okay
because the prequels at least tried
something new
it was never Lord nor Sam so much just
shut down your disrespect of what is
your main issue with road one I mean I
still don't get you don't you'll take
their good movies like you really don't
like them like that I I watch rogue one
see okay force awakens I was kind of
like all right it's okay
letting but it's not it's not that good
in my my big my big issue going on was
just it was it wasn't like a franchise
anything this thing comes out is like is
like popular
I was on Twitter with my reign page with
a command like completely joking I even
see suicides going I was saying I've
seen it and this dude thought I thought
I kidnapped his mom or something I was
it was a popular opinion that Suicide
Squad sucked
if the narrative becomes that it sucks
because it sucked you know then you
can't be you can't be called a bandwagon
or like his new name is j2h man for the
last two years my motto has been
everything you love is garbage one I
think I had an issue with was eat
watched like fan fiction where it was oh
let me have the super original character
who has no faults like what literally I
watched the movie and I can revert what
her name is
like maybe the only character I thought
was interesting was the robot the ABS
which is cool but other than that though
I asked you one question
name one fault that she had with her
character he takes like his his little
note paper your name what's her name
I don't know but she's a rebel rebel she
name one character that was new
introduced give me one name are we
talking about Rome yeah wrote one all
right
URIs you you you realize the reason that
no one knows her name no one knows any
kind of you know reference to any of
these people is because they died that's
telling me is like sovereign points for
us Disney you know and I think that on
what we got to look at right now is that
being at that kind of hands off you know
just kind of like the first time with
this ei situation that they've gotten
hands on because it gave them negative
life you know also we see what happened
Marvel heroes you know there was a rumor
that um there was some type of
misconduct by the higher-ups and the
action of one which cause the whole
studio now to be shut down in the mall
would pull their their contract from
them so it's interesting to see the
effect of negative publicity and what it
can do in gaming and I think you know
maybe Disney now does take a more
hands-on approach as far as you know
have a little bit more control and
watching their properties and stuff like
that but that's what I gotta say Lenny
we don't know what the Lord's got to say
on the rest of it when Disney oh we good
scenarios where this is gonna happen
there's just not like anything pretty
much Disney owns this could happen too
because you gotta have a company that
cares about their ips more than they
care about the money like I said he had
they had not been an uproar over this we
wouldn't have heard anything not the
reason they aren t they care about their
IP more than they care about
a little money that that game would have
gone mm-hmm right and there's a room
again don't quote me this is a rumor
I've been hearing that because of what
happened with eiated there's a rumor
that they're unhappy threatened I don't
know how true that is but I did hear
that number two best-selling console
spots so additional Odyssey was the
top-selling in five days but actually
the top NPD game with two top-selling
game of the month they are not digital
scale sales so you need to get on that
and they leave in italics and yet Mary
Miller shall award we had a Saxon
origins at number two so that poll that
we did have with who would finish it
looks like it was the Assassin's Creed
and Mariel Odyssey combo and yeah watch
daylight anchor now and keep in mind
we'll the site didn't have any online
sales either counted on this one either
so $30 price because they even feel
comfortable paying that for that's
interesting a little weird yeah body
what up I'm still buy all right I tried
a chord wise but since I can well sleep
oh yes I mean I'm not surprised this one
I mean Wolfenstein as as comparatively
is not as big of a franchise as
Assassin's Creed which had a year off
when people actually wanted to play it
and you know Mario Odyssey which I mean
I played it like I had a good time with
it it was a good thirty back that's good
I'm glad that you did that you purchased
it your trading doesn't count sir thank
you talk about stuff in this podcast
that we talked about we're not doing
that right did that's not going to
happen
oh that's fantastic
like I said I voted I voted for
Assassin's Creed Mario I knew it would
be that our combination for the simple
fact at some speed is actually something
that we care about this year um and
Marial the juggernaut bro we've been
waiting for that juggernaut to hit that
switch and it's on honestly to be honest
which I'm so happy for Nintendo that
they're riding a wave of good positive
results in his yielding financial gain
for them yeah just a little bit worried
as great as I'm worried that they busted
they got a little early like you know
I'm hoping they have they have some
carryover obviously but it's not going
to be I feel like big percentage thought
that in October
small percentage is gonna buy that know
what you might have to do is just mute
your you in mute entirely the take
account and then just join it on your
phone or something like that that's what
I do that's I do but you know I still
think they got it November man like well
this man I don't think they got it
because you know
thing is doing more numbers than I
originally anticipated and I you guys
remember I was given this this this
ain't gonna do nothing I'm so happy that
it's you know what it is is the fact
that what Phil's vision was you know
these guys at Microsoft got a chance to
see what it does and how it transforms
old games if anybody gets a chance to
see what it does to old games I don't
care what you're saying you're like I'm
getting rid of my ass this gotta go to
get this like I'm so happy that you know
anchor to be honest with you um when we
was talking you know background talk and
you know I was really thinking about
damn how come I'm an get one um you
understand because I'm saying it from
this perspective I'm like how come I'm
gonna get one and then I saw the twitter
pic and stuff like that I was really a
lady like inside I felt really good um
and if other people get a chance to see
that not know environment of a Best Buy
or a Target or whatever in the
environment of your home and the game
that you love that you put in and in
comes new again that that instant
gratification of what it does is instant
it's not a promise of later
it's a promise of now mm-hm and when you
see it you like whoa it's that's great
it's the Steve effect is when you go you
grab this card in your computer the
first thing you do is go to steam and
see how that changes your games yeah and
the thing that pushed me over the edge
about the whole issue was that when I
when I watched um I was a dog John let
him in from a digital foundry posted the
picture of Wolfenstein the new Colossus
is being super sampled on to ADP and I
play put like 2030 hours into
Wolfenstein is I been I have been around
that corner at least 60 times and when I
saw that and it was improved I was like
wow I need that now I got a question for
you has it justified your person's being
that she wasn't a day one purchase
purchaser and you didn't you know
pre-order or whatever and you saw it
after the fact
after you got in your house and you
decided to check on your own did it
justify your purchase after seeing it
for me I played a bunch of older games
yeah my thing was I wanted to see what
performance was and right now the game
that's telling me this was worth it
is dead by daylight yeah a game with no
patch a game nothing and that game I
used to think used to be the netcode
which is the reason why I ran like
garbage because it was like if you were
promptly with anyone that had any sort
of ranged attacks or a lunging attack it
was basically unplayable you couldn't
there was no way you could get any kills
with that right it was such a pain in
the ass to do and so I I noticed it
especially with that one because then
the framerate was staying locked and
then it would think everything ran
smooth and now if you have an X you have
an advantage you could actually kill
people yeah and you can get it in the
first try and I also noticed it -
especially with overwatch anytime a new
carrier overwatch you anytime a new
character comes out whatsoever what will
happen is everybody rushes through the
new character is and with overwatch
because you load the games the fast to
settle the group you have at least a
clear 15 like to the 15 seconds to pick
whoever you want and everyone else is
still trickling in yeah you get the
advantage to pick who you want to play
us first
yeah I've said that a couple of times
with our what I experienced in destiny
loading and Matt before the end I was
like crazy fault
on the nightfall I was literally you
know they made four were you gotta get
past the two tanks before my load in I
was already at the tank room hitting the
switches shooting the second tank as it
came down and then the NPC's
was was dropping in and these guys was
coming into the boy it was the first day
to happen and I was like this is Savage
and I loved every drop of it oh but I
love
Mirror's Edge
shout-out to Lord Chris we saw that
together you know him in his house me in
my house we weren't really together
oh but putting the game on and seeing
the 360 game running in 4k it was kind
of like you know this is the first time
it lived up to the promise we have
PlayStation 2 which didn't live up to
the promise remember when we saw the
Final Fantasy the guys moving and we
like oh it's kind of look like that that
CGI we're gonna get it no when the
Nintendo 64 remember before they went to
a cartridge and it was on disk and it
was showing their Final Fantasy and all
that other stuff we never received those
graphics a lot of stuff that we -
basically it's coming close to to what
these things these actions rendered you
still robot man no it's filled in lie
fill didn't lie and he said it's going
to help out all your older games you're
gonna see it is gonna be immediate and
everybody thought it was hopeless oh I
thought it was hype thought it was the
lose in the background trying to divert
your attention from the PlayStation
juggernaut and it wasn't it was just
actual facts it was actual factual I
mean this is this gonna go into my topic
a little bit later and I'm gonna tell
you exactly the crap that's going on now
but I'm really happy for any anyone that
was able to purchase the system there
could not afford any games if you
couldn't afford any games and you know
this Black Friday get game pass it's $1
um and you put in your old games they're
new again those games that you didn't
finish you go back in like whoa I'm
actually going back to play Gears of War
4 with low Cognito because he didn't get
the chance to play it and he had a game
that he had on the Shelf that he wanted
to get into and it's awesome
who said
was not with little Chris while watching
Mirror's Edge which I want to do if I'm
still button man way to crash it and
bring it back what you guys gonna do
well I was gonna say all you have to do
is literally what what I do whenever I
have a situation like this is I'll take
the I'll put on I'll take my laptop
wherever I'm hosting the show on mute
everything you all the sound and then
just literally click the link on my
phone to join and then just your account
yeah Judd from the phone cuz yeah I've
tried different things Mike the whole
bit but you know I'm gonna fart Wyatt
right now you should believe in come
back but if I leave the Lee's gonna drop
and it'll be fine for about five minutes
so as long as you just come back but
yeah like the game I want to test out
real quick like this is what I can't do
it right now but I'm also waiting for
the patch on its far out for because all
out for because that one hasn't gotten
the official patch just yet but the big
thing I want to see what that one is the
draw distance and how quickly everything
loads in because there's a mod that I
use its the reverse-flash mod and so you
can play with it you know the
reverse-flash suit you could run you can
run real fast and so with the other game
like if you if you put yourself up to
max speed within like at least five six
seconds you can hit the end of it you
can hit the end of the render it won't
go any farther you're going at the max
speed there and that that's like blink
and you missed the entire town like at
that kind of speed
it's it's really crazy I know I want to
I want to try on the X eventually
whatever that patch comes through
because they're supposed to be
increasing the render distance and the
far the trees load in so that's what I
want to see and then it's God lighting
and all that kind of stuff so yeah it
gives you stuff to look forward to in OD
games I got it I got a big list of games
that I want to play the Final Fantasy my
so digital foundry did a whole thing on
Final Fantasy for the pro versus the ex
and I played it on the pro and I ended
it on the pro and I say you know what
I'm gonna get it for the eggs I'm just
trying to figure out how I'm gonna fit
it in with all these games is that I'm
picking up shadow war this week for the
Black Friday it's a lot of games and
what I want to pick up the fourth day
you go some way better with the actual
the other one you can't join the great
good did you lords laugh again yes so
it's a lot of games that I want to play
and this has is this the best time and
video gaming I mean from a Playstation
standpoint to a Nintendo standpoint to
Xbox standpoint to be playing I mean
because we're at a pinnacle point right
now with a fidelity and the sound
actually meet cuz before we was getting
great sound Dolby Digital sound Dolby
surround sound dolby atmos found we're
getting these sounds but the fidelity
actually wasn't there now with this 4k
systems we're actually getting fidelity
and we're getting the the ambiance to go
with it we had a point right now where
is merging I mean in the controls is
there because of the 60 frames per
second you know or 30 frames locked
that's is reaching that point where we
had a Holy Trinity of video game and
where we're playing the best games that
we can possibly play now I think they go
back to what anchor was saying to with
you know the 1080p owners like a lot of
people still are saying like you know
they don't they're not seeing the
reasons why they should pick up this
system for 1080p the truth of the matter
is that I think Microsoft more and more
they realize that the 4k narrative is
fantastic but it's a it's a hard sell
for people who still haven't made that
jump and and honestly a lot of people
haven't made that jump yet so you're
gonna see more and more they're going to
be leaning into this these performance
most is 1080p 60 or unlocking the frame
rate or whatever the case may be
so you're gonna see those differences
more and more I think I think they're
gonna lean more into that narrative um
it's something that
I know this like I talked about a little
while ago like that Assassin's Creed
like the rogue you throw that game on
and the game is you know it's a nice you
know
Black Flag follow up on a 360 and you
put it on and it's all of a sudden
running it for kicks it's different the
second he like wait a minute they didn't
do anything to this game like that is
something that you that's really
palpable on any screen a 1080p screen so
also on these 1080p screens like the
games that are giving you that 60 frames
per second mode you have not seen that
on your one like this no you're gonna
play that and you're gonna you're gonna
lose your mind with the super sampling
the game is gonna look look and run so
beautifully it is an obvious change over
what you had before it's it's very
obvious like going back to the
Wolfenstein thing to Wolfenstein is
always been a game that ran at 60 with
the super sampling on a 1080p TV the
game looks for and again there are there
are 1080p screens nowadays I'm if you're
buying a 1080p screen now there are some
that may handle HDR because um that's
that's kind of it is ridiculous what the
HDR to me is the biggest game-changer
about this game changing not the 4k it's
that age it's that HDR it's that easier
so the people on the fence who are not
in the market about 4k TV yet you guys
really really need to get online
look at these 1080p super sample
comparisons you're gonna see a huge
difference the machine-man we said it
last week you know or what yeah yeah we
went on an xbox ran up to speed was
going we were talking about the praises
due to the xbox and is the best time to
be alive where we're getting the Holy
Trinity of gaming where we're getting
the fidelity we're getting a sound and
we're getting play control I mean um
somebody did some real funny crap
yesterday on our Twitter they put out an
actual football game with an overlay of
Madden and it had me messed up for a
second for a second because
they actually had the steel is throwing
a touchdown and I said yo oh I saw that
yeah it was like a me I'm gonna tell you
right now I was just about the gold
straight to the market please make
someone to get this topic moving if
possible as far as we did the AP and X
hold it down Hank I appreciate that as
we dance which hardwire but on yeah man
so what I want to do is I want to get
the the gaming awards discussion going
we got Ben to me coming next month so
why not you crown your Lord so this is
gonna work with the crown the Lord
hashtag is going to be we're gonna do
the video game awards to their
categories but they're obviously not
gonna want to every single category I'm
gonna do stuff by importance we're not
doing best eSport player and we got Lord
solve is gonna be our official tally
tally keeper and done who's gonna pick
his blame him exactly the audio of it
will be recorded
everyone's gonna cast a vote we think
will win that probably screenshot the
actual well I would if I wasn't happy
I'm just a know the ILP account right
now but we could do our lads it's all
good so let's start off with the most
anticipated game
so I'm gonna start from the bottom to
the top and the nominees are God of War
marvel spiderman monster hunter world
read dem [ __ ] Red Dead Redemption - and
the Last of Us part 2 we as the Lords
voting read dead 2 is not coming out
next year just just so you know Geoff
Keighley doesn't carry but Shenmue 3 on
2 years ago so dude though so what do we
got Lord anchor you do jumping in for
crown crown your Lord what do you what
do you need us that's a real tough one
because that's really more it's a tough
it's really a toss-up between last two
US two and Red Dead Redemption - but I'm
probably going in terms of the winner
Red Dead Redemption - because the love
for Rockstar is ridiculous it makes no
sense and but also the fact that it is
multi plat and if it's done by popular
vote
chances are more people voted for it got
you
Lord addict what are you voting most
anticipated game - Lord King and a clean
sweep ready my lord solve we'll be
breaking the tower you're going against
the grain what you doing I did that was
first he was first in the mix my bad we
get the order gonna be saying the same
thing that you
[Laughter]
moving along we're gonna get into now
best multiplayer voting and the nominees
are Call of Duty or what - no definitely
fortnight Mario Kart 8 deluxe Pub G in
splatoon - Lord anchor that's it that's
a real close one - because I feel like
that one's probably between destiny -
and pub G I'm probably only work for its
pub G on this one for the sole reason of
everybody's trying to copy it now right
start their train starting that wave
Lord addict
what are you voting I actually think
it's between fortnight and pub G like I
want to say I want to say pugsy but I
would not be surprised at fortnight
Windsor one that's being played right
now put your sword down you got a vote
with Josh what's gonna be Jesus to has
more hope you still has more people
playing though like they have two
million concurrent players on PC only
Lord addict
a final vote please
loss up yeah haven't played pub G but I
had to say pub G yeah they have to say
that we have a look King are we breaking
this are we weak enough of me betting
against Bob G I lost twice I will
actually agree definition have been the
knee I don't know what
he needs a win go with pub Jesus well
we're gonna move on its best sports
slash racing game the nominees are 5 for
18 Forza Motorsport 7 GT sport NBA 2k 18
Pro Evolution Soccer 18 and project cars
2 Lord
yes that would that would comes down to
the GT sport or Forza because I normally
I'd say FIFA normal normally I'd say
FIFA but this year I'd even know FIFA
released
yeah they had no height going into this
one it was just it was quiet and Pro
Evolution is not gonna win we all know
that 2k teens not gonna win really I
think they might lean more towards fours
on this one because at all you know
capabilities it really is the better
game popular people popular people yeah
that's the only downside pic tures
effort for the sake of it all right so
you got forza lord Haddix your favorite
category sports big microtransaction
backlash so that's not it I didn't even
know FIFA I was coming out this year I
didn't even know there was another song
oh but project cars to that I guess I
mean I'm just gonna say I'm gonna say GT
sports although Forza okay cool I don't
like people like graphics when they like
game play these days GT sport alright
better Lord King what you going I'm
wrong with GT sport understand our
forces stomps it into the ground
I'm graphically - don't don't don't
don't get caught up in a ball
they got great playbacks that's nice but
I'm going with the majority of the
people and I think PlayStation people
vote more okay over the platform leader
okay
yes tough I'm probably would narrow it
down between I didn't play GT sport
obviously I've seen the comparisons and
heard you know graphically you know that
they've done in the tracks that they
have compared in to forces that they
have that it's been better
I'm still gonna go with it with the
title Hold'em single sources seven you
know I like to K 18 but this [ __ ] was a
little bit of a down here door
transactions mic retract a little - Wow
shout out a little bit money check I
know ya voted before when I'm rolling
yeah I'm okay but I'm running with a
four seven we always appreciate royalty
Lord RAF in the chat so of course now we
got the next category we need to discuss
cuz we need this how how we handle the
doors to forget laws like do we are we
condoning beheadings on this is how we
do with that if you forget a stipulation
it will always result you going in your
wallet
it was seven I'm sorry I've only played
demos of Forza and GT GT has some
beautiful HDR but I think fours is the
more accessible game the larger game
more variety and it'll make you want to
drive they don't make you gotta win one
on this all right moving on
best strategy game all this or that
gonna be so high for this category
oh let's start with low deck but uh I
mean Laura anchor if we're gonna do Halo
Wars to marry oh rabbits Kingdom battle
entail total war war hammer to and XCOM
to one of the chosen are the nominees
Lord Anka what is your vote for the best
strategy game rabbits they because that
that was the game that nobody expected
to be good nobody it was it was an okay
game I didn't finish it because I just
didn't really care I really care for
strategy games in general but I had a
good time playing it when I had it
zygarde anchor this is probably one of
your favorite categories and something
I'm very curious to see what you're
gonna vote you a lot of your heart is in
this category
I like ex-con to is gonna get overlooked
because it was an expansion and it was
the
and it can't the initial release came
out you know at an okay time but the
console version came out it at a
horrible time and then it was broken
Mario Plus rabbits there's a good chance
it's neither between that or Halo Wars
to do I don't see the other I don't know
total hammers a huge game okay Warhammer
I fell Caleb ores to its I gotta go
within this because I put like 12 days
ago Robert George shouts a little chief
timing to chat he said I told a
Warhammer bow-wow
Lord solve this is not really a you know
a category I'm really into but man that
Mario rabbits brought me in man like I'm
definitely gonna try out Halo Wars to at
some point an ex-con so uh but that
Mario ravages will brought me in some
ago with that no doubt no doubt
Lord King what is your vote rabbits wow
I think I'm gonna go but a break the
mold I think I'm going to go with XCOM
to only because as much as I love Mario
rabbits I just fell ex-con was the
better game overall and I liked what
they were doing with the new one but I
probably not gonna win this one but I'm
gonna go against the grain
you know what to was great but uh I
think I'm going with XCOM 2 so that's
what we got on best strategy game voting
now this is a funny category best family
game voting nominees are Mario Kart 8
Mario rabbits sonic mania splatoon 2 and
super Mario's Odyssey
let me say something real quick before
we go okay why is mario artisan writing
manian is like that's why why is mario
kart on there it's a rerelease did you
guys actually hear that the the category
family nintendo equals family of course
via Nintendo ruled when I tell you this
it's gonna be a Nintendo friends
let's make sure it's make passing on
this either but it would anchor you've
oh god I'll probably even give it to
Mario Cart out of all those assembling
in has true multiplayer yeah this little
co-op adventure yep
family game yeah it got a lot of
attention when he got re-released about
it though the only thing about it though
that might hurt its chances is simply
because it won last year for best racer
no make no sense for category no doubt
Lord
addict what is your vote that's family
game I think it's between splatoon two
and mariokart mariokart
okay alright lots off what is your vote
same thing Mario Kart I think it's
between those two because it's just a
multiplayer component and the
multiplayer component and Odyssey is
it's kind of crappy so no it's
unplayable once you have it I like doc
remember your family game so yeah yeah
looking at family yeah same because it's
multiple people that's how you're going
as opposed to okay I got you
Lord King what did you I don't know what
Lord Drake says what's old to you is new
to me baby I'm going with Mario Kart
because I did not buy it on the Wii U
and it looks fantastic on my switch and
it's a no release not re-release for me
everyone they're like the only other
game that they own that can compete with
a family like that is Mario Party and
that's not yeah that's true
yeah yeah I'm going with Mara cop
surprise I thought I was gonna be the
only person on the mario kart train but
there yeah that was real fun somewhat
fun with as a grouping you know it's
simple to get into so I got the Mario
Kart 8 deluxe alright moving right along
that's fighting game another favorite of
Lord addicts Oh
that now having these are arms injustice
to Marvel vs. Capcom 2 which I don't
know what is Tekken 7 so lord anchor
well we all know nidhogg is the pity
nomination honestly though if I if I had
to pick one I mean I don't need to play
tagging that much for me they'll
probably give to injustice too cuz
actually have characters like even the
even the casuals get on board with that
Scott DC characters in it so we'll
probably win no doubt Lord
addict your favorite category that's
that's good logic I like how you rockin
which would you go with arms and justice
to more vs capcom infinite mighty honey
but not the best positive loss are you
about to say something and you're okay
yeah I mean my pick is injustice I think
I go anchor on that like it's just the
DC characters the fact they have like
Ninja Turtles come in like it's just
it's one of those things where like the
casual the casual sort of gravitate to
that but fact that nidhogg that nidhogg
might make the first nidhogg was it's
just it's like a funny like uh a lot
they kind of classified is like Bushido
blade but like looking orrible but the
gameplay is kind of amazing so you you
know this is a game that came out on
console I think it came out on PC - yeah
it might be a surprise because a lot of
people like nidhogg know it's off you
going home no no I'm going in just
because they pay them for that promo I
got my behind ripped inside go what
injustice unfair enough a strong choice
I am going against the grain I know I'm
probably going to lose I'm too much of a
Tekken 7 fanboy I'm going with Tekken 7
it's gonna lose good smash I don't care
that's what I'm I'm only willing to do
that with one category knows where they
wore to nothing else
noctus they got Noctis for final fantasy
15 good jeez Howard get in the chat I
see the nominees are divinity original
sin - Final Fantasy 15 Nier automata
persona 5 I could hear like high bar -
now South Park fractured but whole the
best role-playing game I feel I've
played it I don't know anything about it
all I know is it got a lot of good press
for like three weeks prior and it came
out and people were loving it so Lord
addict what are we voting on what wait
hold on you're losing
all the Final Fantasy which I've heard
Raisin Bran using Final Fantasy came out
last year at the very end of the year
persona yeah
this year persona is in my you know it
still holds that RPG you know that
foundation with it I don't even know why
near all is on that I don't know is that
an RPG or just an action of intro game
give you praise just gave you a
PlayStation I don't know what's going on
with the Lord of mooch can be purchased
[Laughter]
I gotta go with divinity to man this
thing got so much I mean the people talk
about what greatest RPG ever like when
you start throwing that stuff around
like I played it yeah I'm waiting for it
to come to console because the first one
came so I'll just play it on console but
yeah I think it could be that the
Minotaur and a really good point about
that too because I yeah Final Fantasy
doesn't look like it's got a chance
because the game words are there it's
all about what have you done for me
lately okay Lord King personified okay
even though I got it is still in the
plastic I haven't played it because I
really hate my playstation this is tough
I mean I've heard well exactly what no
arguments and far as divinity just wish
I knew more about it for me can you know
Final Fantasy I just got now shadow -
look I persona 5 seems to be
the favorite here I mean if they're
gonna win something this is the category
I see it so yeah I got it I gotta be
small much as I want it to be final I'm
gonna go a persona 5 on this one all
right so we are moving alone best
action-adventure game and the nominees
are Assassin's Creed's origins went
horizon zero dawn super married yo
Odyssey uncharted lost legacy and that
game the WoW decade Lord
Horacio Dawn has agreed origins Super
Mario Odyssey your favorite your goal on
Charlotte's legacy though the breath of
the wild what that one in particular I'm
really up on the air on this one because
I have not played this absence period
origins yet I'm starting up today I just
haven't got around to it yet so I can't
really give an accurate picture on that
but I can tell you Mario artist he's not
gonna win let's just sell them maybe in
maybe horizons are done cuz right sir
that's not winning Game of the Year okay
this is the consolation you flowing with
it alright
Lord addict it's a tough boy what you
got okay III think I stuff man it is
tough for the chassis
I hate no Marriott's a winning game of
the year before Uncharted wins this
category mark see I feel like I I feel
like you know when people think
action-adventure they're gonna lean
towards more they act
orientated game so I'm gonna take that
out of it yeah that's nice too I think
it comes down to Legend of Zelda
Assassin's Creed origins and horizon
zero dawn and for some reason I feel
like they're gonna give it the horizon
out to horizon okay well it won't get it
won't win game of the year but this is
where horizon politics right here okay
okay
Lord saw I'm curious because you are
invested in almost every property here
probably - it's not so you play all of
these more than what is doesn't yeah
uncharted is nice it doesn't stand a
chance in hell like neither than cesium
um I think I think I do
my general feeling is Zelda FTW like I
think horizons gonna get the pity win
here because it's not winning anything
else like go with horizon all right King
you also have a lot experience here so
I'm actually gain that can actually win
a category I'm gonna go with Ubisoft
actually the bag is secured in this
fraction right here because you talk
about action and I'm betting it's Elda
it's too far in a year and people is
gonna be putting that to game of the
year so I'm gonna go with Assassin's
Creed so they can get something out of
this category so two categories are in -
right you're right this is Tom I mean
shout to the chat that's really really
mad at us for not really giving Mary all
these props I love Mario
but it stopped Mario for me in this
carrier when I saw the word action a lot
of parts were you walking around looking
at stuff
honestly I'm late to zero dawn I just
got it
you know I'm literally play like a stage
[Laughter]
when I get out of that little story
fantastic stories good but that's a game
you should be line because after a while
after a while the combat gets tiresome
how many times Creed to win this war but
the problem I have with it I can't pick
it over Zelda I just felt my
predecessors Creed this carries just a I
don't like I felt the fighting is a
little clunky yeah I think Zelda's
tighter as far as the fighting and
controlling them and you know I don't
forget anything that they do they could
do no wrong I got you that's a baby it
is that it's the competition in its
genre is no no you know what it is you
have shown what matters in addicts world
actually gain we go the nominees are
cuphead destiny Oh to kneel pray God
Howard's
favorite size competition is no no
competition like if you want action this
game is action incarnate like this is
this game it's picked up where they
could from Doom
they kept immense so if you want the BJ
at least the dude that is get on us for
Satan inappropriate things charge of the
Sheep action game what are you voting
I think prey has no chance in hell
cuphead I don't think it has a chance
it's like yo and it is no really I don't
I do the same thing cool cool Lord solve
this is this going which game yeah I
have to go with addict on this one I
mean I got prey doesn't have a chance in
hell and a Wolfenstein destiny both
first-person shooters I kind of would
prefer there to be in that category and
covered as great as it is it's kind of
isolated to Xbox and PC
you know same thing with neo but neo to
me man
that you put out with my heart I put but
hours into this let me ask you you
haven't touched Wolfenstein yet or I'm
just curious
oh I play Wolfenstein look I love me
some Wolfenstein I played definitely
Wolfenstein is you unit you the trackers
right carefully here and in
balls-to-the-wall action it's there
maybe you can play differently - that's
the thing neo you can't really you have
to you have to get into the fight with
Wolfenstein you can play it sneakily you
don't necessarily have to it you can
play it completely differently neo you
gotta fight this is straight-up action
so to me I'm going with Neil is
Wolfenstein mainly just a shoot-'em-up
game like be it Superman don't sit there
in like Tiger code is it mainly game
it's um it's in terms of like if you
want to play it so you shoot him up I
play everything stealth I play with my
thing is you go stealthy you get caught
and then you know it's gonna be a good
action game but I feel like the other
one you know it just it it has more
going for in that genre than a knock on
Wolfenstein - I love me Wolfenstein but
the guns don't feel great like there's
not a lot of rubble it's not a rumble
when you're shooting like it's a
shooting and you know you should have
some feedback on your controller and it
is really nothing well yeah nothing
about my from my face is white guy
blinking beam right now I need you vote
I think I'm a roll
I think I'm rolling with Lord echo in
this van I mean I it's unfair to me
although because way and I trust Lord
saw I do
trust and I know yeah go with it but I
just felt the even though the first 15
20 minutes was down was so amazing to be
yeah I think I have to go understand
it's a tough one but I wouldn't be mad
if Neto pulled it you were saying
something like you know you're gonna be
back on here when we go over these
results right not kick I have a question
should we be doing vest VRA are all
right we'll get him voting cap head
he'll blades no sacrifice night in the
woods pyre or what remains of Edith
Finch no anchor head only because I'm
close on Edith inch but Edith inches an
established studio now with sorry
sparrow and it hurts by gonna say cup it
because those guys actually don't like
sacrifice their houses and I gotta give
a debut Eddie game were props than you a
sequel Fidel Lord attic okay catch it
Lord soft it's gonna be tough for you
yeah I love you Dan Finch you like help
lead help blade is fantastic but it's
yeah yeah three weeks there it was like
big thing like it was a big event I
gotta go with what got its own sneakers
cup it the consensus is cup and I'm
actually going with cup head as well the
new category best ongoing game destiny
to Grand Theft Auto 5 overwatch I have
to go back and forth because you want
all the way back to the bottom for that
rebel succeeds in warframe Longacre best
ongoing game best thing I got I got a
vote of my heart on this one this is my
is my category because oh maybe the
thing is GTA will probably win because
GTA is just had a sane amount of support
and Rockstar wants to milk that base as
long as possible
I love overwatch to win but I gotta go
with siege going siege over overwatch
based on your own watch love though hi
I'm Sasha it's it's this is more people
playing seats than overwatch right now
max just they're gonna decide the men
from the boys
Lord addict nice that's the safe choice
he trying to better I get W I feel that
he play no games same person this said
two minutes ago he gonna come back on
here and get the waz every time somebody
bets with a heart and give away one this
guy got something to say GTA I would
like to go with over wives but GTA got
the numbers and actually you got a look
at what the title says best ongoing game
like this it's gotta be I mean I would
love all my heart don't I'm gonna vote
for Rainbow six only because
forfeiting crowning alright so that's
all going gay we got that game for
impact
alright big escape that we all don't see
the fence yeah best performance we could
skip that best score in music best audio
design deftly to hell blaze and so no
sacrifice seven Mario Odyssey or Zelda
brethren wild hopefully it's nothing
it's very unique
none like that that's my vote alright
best score in music we are going cuphead
destiny to Nier automata persona 5 Super
Mario Odyssey and zeldo do they even
have a score in music in Zelda but
anyway votes please acre for the sole
reason of I like old music and they
literally they told the composer all you
have to do is just work on one premise
yeah what in video games are created in
the 1930s and just build music with that
style mm just for in the badge is
perfect yeah I want to say yes they took
about the old destiny should have one
score was in my opinion Oh Lord so
covered no no okay good alright I am
probably just stuff
yeah I might have to go a cup it's true
to the era you know best art direction
we downed it last through Yahoo so don't
worry about okay we got you persona 5
Zelda breath of the wild which won best
art direction okay moving along Best
narrative
Hellblazer Sunna arises oh darn near
automata what remains of Edith Finch and
Wolfenstein anchor me into I'm actually
really torn on this finale enough
because this [ __ ] was really really
good youth [ __ ] is really really good
the end like Wolfenstein two stories
just great but they don't the only
reason I'm torn on this was because I
felt like the individual stuff was wolf
well what would mean zfh was a better
narrative but Wolfenstein he had one
consistent character art for 15 hours as
opposed to Edith's inch which was two
hours and we had a bunch of little short
stories so like by like 1% of my kind of
internal vote Wolfenstein yeah well they
won't come back to me Lord sauce
Wolfenstein mm mr. tough ones on King
does either Finch's deep right it's
tough I can play he'll play but I heard
so much good stuff about it but this is
narrative so I'm gonna go man this is
tough it's gonna now doubt it's between
Edith Finch and Wolfenstein for me I'm
gonna go with Wolfenstein only because I
like the subject matter that was touched
in the katakana characters that were
brought back and the connections there
but even if it definitely could deserve
this too but I'm going Wolfenstein what
are you going with low data I'm coming
back to you boy Oh bleh
all right
and now final to fast game direction
Horacio dawn was an evil seven Superman
Odyssey Wolfenstein - Zelda breath of
the wild Lord anko that's game direction
because game direction is that it's
supposed to be about something that it's
it's doing something different in how
the game's approach mm-hmm she led to
the cell that comes real close on that
one for me because they literally just
open up the gates and said do what you
want to do drew up a world kind of deal
the only difference about that one
though is like it's yes it's novel no
it's new it's it's new and interesting
for Nintendo but in tendo's behind ten
years so but no what no one was climbing
up like garage my comment that ring so
they're doing stuff that know they've
got systems that is existed in other
games but they tell me they've that like
the combination of all these systems in
one day expanded but I personally got to
give it a wolfenstein to what's up so
the hands down the only one that comes
close is resin even seven yeah that's
also say that even come close because he
did something different in a way you
know simply what you say lord King
holler and the final category I do have
a request
yes well in art and art alleys
let's make Game of the Year two points
that's a big one no I like that I like
two points for gave me it's on a record
now we have two final vote to Lord Kings
happiness dawn dawn personified pub G
and Zelda breath little while
keep in mind pop G is in the game of the
[Laughter]
[Music]
year
considering Jeff Healey broke all the
rules now now where now we're just
accepting any game into here
next year I'll win game of the year for
the best concept imagine I have a game
called supreme it's whatever you want it
to be this is the concept phase oh
that's a tough one too because I think
it's really between Legend of Zelda and
Papaji it could be the old the only
thing is though with the pubsey crowd
you got PC guys a PC guys actually vote
you guys vote and there's more people
played it and boys that will vote
because it's there and I hope you know
they cover the droves switch gank is
coming in they're gonna go but then
they're also gonna be split between
Mario Odyssey rule that's the point
they're gonna be split between the two
of them and so that's gonna ruin the
vote then you guys you know you know
there's a decent install base that
people are switches that have a but then
then there's something you're not
considering what's gone well we're not
considering Xbox crowd will be mobilized
for pub G yeah all the representation
they have you're right no you're right
that's the you got the first Xbox crowd
I gotta give it to pub G I don't want it
to win but I think it will okay fair
enough
Lord addict I am curious I want to say
Zelda you breakin my heart
you breaking my heart right but they
broke the laws that's sacred to us
yeah I don't care I can't in good
conscience like I'm not mad I'm not mad
that Pope G's there honestly I'm not mad
like other people
look man Rhoda is my game with you here
but they're gonna get at the bottom Park
Jean
yeah this thing yeah I can't I can't do
it like I as popular that the pub key
thing is commands where we beat them I
gotta go with my heart man I said no not
[ __ ] look King all right I mean you can
look at how many switches is out there
right but just the same way everybody's
in this uproar talking about gene I
didn't know about it until they it so
everybody was talking about the fact
that they changed the rules and put this
game in tag I'm blaming overwatch I'm
calling my heart I'm probably that
winning crowd the Lord this year you
know it I do it so your face but get out
there and do the thing those are our
boats thank you for participating Lord
King I know you have your topic I
apologize and technical difficulties
please define what is going on with the
strategies again alright this topic is
not gonna stand too long it's just gonna
be a quick topic um don't worry about
taking a little difficulties you were
Lord robot today yo alright so I want to
talk about the strategy against
Microsoft at this point in time because
I after the B's has dropped we're gonna
keep calling it to piece the pieces in
the streets the piece is tearing things
up just like they said they would I
really honestly is I'm pleasantly
surprised that is living up to and
exceeding expectations now the Beast
being Xbox 1x if you're oh no and before
when PlayStation and Xbox launched it
was just about PlayStation and Xbox
right it was just a 1080p vs. 720p oh
your pixels are short baby
remember that was a thing and then the
pro came out and then the gap widened it
got ridiculous the gap got crazy it was
like where 1440p with checkerboard and
baby were you doing surfing at 7:20 I
mean it was very terrible in these
streets now
the exes are out and the ex I don't care
what PlayStation side you land on the ex
is stomping you I'm talking about
pumping you whatever game you put up
you're getting stomped down is it it
doesn't make any sense actually digital
foundry should put Xbox wins on
everything all right but you know what
the new narrative is and what I've seen
listen pcs in this category know what a
hell this guy come from
where the hell did it come from Xbox
Playstation Pro oh and we're gonna put
the PC in there just so that something
can have is head over Microsoft because
we'd already know that if you put a two
thousand dollar PC up against a five
hundred dollar machine who's gonna win
thanks man facts are you going with that
I mean this is a good point I mean I've
been hearing this going on right now as
far as you know these comparison I mean
let's just call it what it is digital
foundry is eating this is just digital
looking at the temperature these streets
we are all blood thirsty for these
comparison videos I don't know how it's
so funny like the morning a video comes
up from digital foundry but this versus
this and PC or whatever the views are
insane I'm like the video just was up
ten minutes ago it took me that's the
culture now I think honest its promotes
the console wars it promotes what
everybody's into and I mean I have to
admit as much as the processor was you
know it annoys me sometimes there is
some funniness to it it's the funniness
ascendant but why is it PC interjected
in this now right a fight that's a good
point the thing I think also is that
what's happening is because of the the
memo digital foundry got that exclusives
with the Scorpio on how they broke down
you know the components and how it's
such a great piece of tech and how
they're seeing its
remarkable what Microsoft was able to
accomplish in the $500 box right now I
feel this is what I see that the PC
crowd is threatened the PC crowd feels
like whoa yeah it's good but you know
kind of thing so I think that's where
the uproar is coming up as opposed to
for the most part it's gonna be
PlayStation in majority these comparison
that's just what's gonna happen you'll
have your occasional anomalies like
which you'll have a patch you know I
mean but for the most part we know
what's gonna happen head-to-head so I
think that's just a new wave right now I
think the PC contingent is very loud
because you know no disrespect to my PC
guys I think there is a threat like you
know hey these guys are up there but you
know we gotta show them we can do you
know a little bit more that's my feeling
what you guys do yeah no no joke though
actually you're right about that cuz I
was I was seeing the same thing
yesterday I was watching two guys go at
it and like two relatively big people
arguing about this stuff and I was like
what's going on like so they were
getting mad about their reserves of
supposes master PC build and it was like
it's $500 that it's like but it doesn't
include anything else and so what the
when they try to do because they they
they had this bet between the two
individuals about like can you build an
Xbox 1x that can outperform it or at
least get the same for the same price
with all the same little regular feature
stuff and so basically they said well
you don't have to have the 4k blu-ray
player the guy cheated too and he was
like well I threw in a year of Xbox Live
on top of it oh they know they had one
that had no mouse and keyboard no OS
[Laughter]
include everything right like like like
I think I can get not having the 4k
blu-ray player I can understand that
mmm like it's only 24 bucks it's not
this like you can get a cheap okay you
get the cheapest a 4k blu-ray player
from the resource there but
it's just like it just it annoyed me
because it was like it was just getting
real personal my wife why are you guys
so so hung up about this well you would
be salty too of a dude jumped in your
lane doing your stuff better for cheaper
Lord addict I know how you feel about
the TC contingent sometimes what you're
feeling what do you feel well you know
the whole pcs being compared to
Microsoft the Scorpio as far as the
digital foundry comparisons my comments
is not for a PG I gotta get but do you
do you at least think it's fair do you
think it's unfair oh let me keep him one
time I can I do it I mean I think those
comparisons they've been around for a
long time I know IGN is constantly done
the the the three comparisons and
Nintendo has never really been in the
conversations there's always been a PC
so I mean it's always been there I just
think now it kind of holds my weight
because before like the difference was
obvious and now the difference isn't so
obvious especially for for the price
disparity right so when you look at what
the ex has given you and what it would
apiece he's gonna give you with you know
a $2,000 PC what you gain in terms of
fidelity and stuff like that maybe the
framerate stuff is a big deal but it's
not such a huge difference so I think it
still puts the X in a very good light
because you know you're saying this $500
machine is comparable to this it's not
you know so far removed it's like notice
looks disgusting in comparison it's not
that at all so I still think the X looks
good in that in that light in terms of
like people's strategy other strategies
against Microsoft like what I mentioned
last week with Playstation place is
gonna lean into we have games they don't
have games how whatever that narrative
is they're gonna they're gonna flow with
that right and then they're gonna focus
on making their first party stuff look
as good as possible which they're very
good at doing like last of us is gonna
look amazing
god of war is gonna look amazing you
don't mean so and then there's there's
no point of comparison there right so
they're gonna lean into that stuff
because they have nothing else they
they're gonna have to take that L for as
long as they're gonna have to on the
digital foundry comparisons because
right it is what it is unless they you
know let's say surprise everybody with a
ps5 announcement injects tear after let
you put the icing on your topic what are
you feeling is people don't like and is
a couple of companies is digital foundry
is idea you know by gamestop and is this
other little weirdo guy he comes in and
he's been doing it for a min and I know
he's a PlayStation lover for the simple
fact that I saw the Nintendo switch
launch Skyrim right I wasn't going to
pick it up because I play Skyrim to
death I wasn't boy I sorry and I was
like wow it looks really good so guess
what digital foundries comparison to
Scott PlayStation yeah they put it up
against the PlayStation 4 PlayStation
Pro you know it's funny that's which
held its own its own but again my thing
is they're always trying to show Sony
and this super favorable light yes and
anytime that they're gonna take a loss
they're gonna take a hands-down beatdown
don't worry about this I got you might
do you weigh over 2000 pounds
lightweight to its name the why you put
help you weights in here with these
light weights listen I don't want
Charlie get it twisted III have my
PlayStation I hate it
I hate
um don't get it twisted I've got games
for it I'll purchase I purchase tools I
can get rid of them because I'm not
using it I want you to understand any
game y'all come out with that is multi
plat Xbox one X is going to stomp it
total flaw it's doing no you don't see
true 4k you do checkerboard and even
then you have 1440p your 1440p machine
don't talk about this dynamic 4k in that
dynamic at all bro we know what you
doing we speed allies in you and stop
getting PC to help you out when you
getting mashed out in the corner my 30
continue comfort Alex he had two
questions in the chat when he was
talking about at the do we thing was
gonna be a reveal at the Game Awards we
think is gonna be special
there that was one in the second
question he had was I'm meeting mark so
I was getting more into the PC space
with the One X getting there big games
and what performance that is relatively
close so let's just answer these two
questions for our Lord Victor yes yes
yes yes there's a what did he mean by
reveal what reveal what and that's
always the case I mean I think Geoff
Keighley likes to make sure that people
watch that show so I think this specific
question is what do we think would be
revealed the PlayStation 5 what I'll
tell you right now what they're gonna do
is they're gonna show puppy on the X
with X hmm I like that they would like
that because look at the release date
times good point Hank that it definitely
lines up alright cool start a close up
soon we got the UM new ILP poll this
week courtesy of my man Lord zero so
with the removal of microtransactions
from battlefront to EA has stated that
they will return yes stated that they
will return in the future after
changes are made to the game is this
acceptable a no ei should keep
microtransactions completely out of the
game B yes the business of
microtransactions in gaming is not going
away
or C when can I cop that premium please
Rock the Vote and the ILP Twitter polls
heart when it go up thank you lord
anchorman for holding down my robot self
where can find people find you and the
multiverse bredrin hating on any part
now you can find this on this channel
here the the inner circle network we're
out of Mondays at 8:00 p.m. we got the
gaming community game awards coming out
the middle period of categories yeah
very very honored what is the when the
voting is still going on and what is the
actual wood voting is ongoing there's
links everywhere but a couple tweets and
such so you want to find out all that
good stuff you can go to the iron Lords
uh Twitter account and you can find all
that stuff there so other than that
though we're looking at the 18th of
December as the awards show it won't be
a regular multiverse thing but it's just
it'll be a little award show go check
that out so be be there it'll be ready
nice we appreciate you and shout out to
the entire multiverse bredrin also tick
podcast that went last night noise make
sure you support the entire network so
we gonna get these out trolls poppin
Lord addict we're gonna find people find
you you can find me on Twitter you can
find me on youtube gaming others can
find me on all my gaming gamer tags I
they called PS what is that I know Xbox
cause there's gamer tags this is an ID
yes they're both room to kill I will be
streaming Final Fantasy
seven probably wrong five today so if
you want to come in through on that
stream this morning was quite hilarious
I did enjoy I do want to know it's all I
remembered you that we could find me
actually online on PSN on Twitter and it
real quickly happy Thanksgiving
everybody I will not be in a next week's
show I will be sitting under a palm tree
somewhere having that premium experience
[Applause]
too much of a premium experience when he
does it all social media sites set for
snapchat I would like to tell my take
Network brothers I do watch you your
guys podcast I would love to be in your
chat show just to late at night for me
the cane gets up at midnight to go to
work so I go to sleep early
oh but I do while I'm at work listen to
you guys and um I swear you guys are
hilarious one of my best podcast that I
do listen to other than my own is the
multiverse I I swear
Lord James and anchor and you guys I
really love Dave I really loved it I
really love the stuff so also I damn
sure listen to Brad are always so oh um
salad Rev OH
dangerous challenges actually men who
have the same poster he did that I
already talked to I'm gonna call him on
the carpet of it he's playing in the
past in at 1080
that was lame bro I get you back we got
it we got to cover these 1088 redneck
gaming runs on ILP tell me what you want
to hear but what you need it and thanks
everyone that like you subscribe in the
chat heart also don't forget to catch us
on iTunes Google Play and also the
amazing G in patreon that is in the
description all the help really helps us
big time so I mean that I was biting on
naked man's gonna have to end the show
make sure you I see I see me out here
modeling for y'all it's good ok swagged
out we're gonna direct you to the
website where you can actually purchase
that like and subscribe guys please much
appreciated no not no we are out of here
don't anger me hit that button sir